hey guys I'm just McDonald you're
watching games but news and it's the top
of June today is the last official day
of e3 so let's get cracking into the
good stuff first up let's get the
resolution we step out of the way early
diablo 3 is going to be at 1080p on ps4
but early 900p on xbox one the details
were confirmed by blizzard senior
producer on the console edition who said
that the most important thing to them
has been prioritizing framerate both the
xbox one and ps4 version are gonna run
at 60 frames per second and while we
already did have the PlayStation
framerate confirm now you got the whole
story let me know you prefer a higher
resolution or a higher frame rate in the
comedy box in pretty cool new Zelda
series producer Eiji Aonuma confirms
that that really awesome looking we new
trailers result again what actual
gameplay footage typically we haven't
heard it the whole thing was actual
gameplay or if just part of it was but
the announcement certainly does lend
weight to the growing suspicion that
this game is going to be a big ball of
Awesome we also received further
confirmation that the scope of the
in-game world will be pretty impressive
as a NUMA added I wasn't kidding about
how you will be able to reach the
mountains in the distance if you should
choose to it's not been all sunshine and
rainbows in Nintendo's corner though as
they've said that they don't think
there's anything fun about twitch
screaming so that consumers Nintendo
we're pulling up the rear wrapping the
only new gen platform which doesn't
feature twitch streaming but it seems
they are to us nintendo of america
president Reggie season may told polygon
we directing streaming 30 minutes of
gameplay by itself is a lot of fun they
said they think the track highlight
videos from mario kart 8 airing the
super smash brothers III tournament and
using twitter stream their e3 content
has been effective but they aren't so
keen on taking it further on the console
it's a slightly strange move
tenders which have been booming as a
service but the company has something of
history with adopting new technologies
later than its competitors let me know
if you think this is a big mistake by
Nintendo or if you aren't all that into
quit streaming slaps up for today's tech
odd news goodness Marcus off to Yusuf
Mehdi said that the xbox one's original
policies had the right vision these are
the same policies which were mostly
pretty heavily 180 mehdi explained that
he tinks a digital future for games is
still the way to go and that if they
have communicated their plans better to
consumers and it may have been a
different story Maddy also referenced
the connection list 399 dollar xbox one
explaining that he thinks more connect
will be sold as a result of the decision
to unbundle it he believes that the
price point and connect removal will
make the Box more accessible ultimately
bringing more people over to the system
and then ideally having them us to pick
themselves up a connector round off the
Xbox one experience let me know down in
that comment box whether you reckon more
connects are going to be sold as a
result of the move and what you think
about mehdi comments i'll be back
tomorrow with my top 5 favorite stories
that came out of III this year so if you
just after the biggest and best then
that'll be the place to be